here's what's happening life is very  simple when you think about business  it's supply and demand and attention and  storytelling simple the reason I've been  successful is because I'm stupid I need  go to a lot of classes in a lot of  schools and learn do all the things that  [ __ ] us up  I kept the basic it's very simple if you  have something people want they'll buy  it and then you push the price you  should assume in it how did I launch  vaynermedia when clients started coming  to me like how much I'm like $5,000 a  month they're like okay and then that's  what I'm like ten thousand dollars a  month and then they're like okay then  that's a very good and then the next one  is like $15,000 a month and they were  like okay good looks like yeah and then  this is now oh nine I was like $20,000 a  month and they were like [ __ ] you as a  1515